hey there i'm edmund tran and i'm joined
by Dan hi hey and what we're doing today
is we're taking a look at the 30-minute
metal gear solid 5 phantom pain demo
konami released very recently and we're
going to go through it because dan
especially has some questions that have
popped up after watching this video so
they went through a lot of stuff went
through a lot of mechanics that there
are certain things that we notice that
raise mysteries yeah there is a lot
happening in this video but there's
still quite a lot more happening if you
look very closely which I did hey yes if
you watch this like till like five
possum Japanese anime yes alright so
let's go to the first mystery alright
let's do that ok so the first thing I
noticed in this video is that down in
the bottom right you'll see this heroism
currency pop up and that's a currency
that was actually present in a metal
gear solid peace walker hmm for the PS
Vita and what it is is it's kind of a
measure of how good / soldier you are so
you know this is primarily a stealth
game right and in big boss isn't really
meant to be going all out guns blazing
even though you can yeah especially in
this one it's a lot easier to fix your
mistakes exactly exactly so you gain
heroism by performing missions in kind
of the most stealthy and professional
way possible so not being seen not
raising alarms not getting shot and not
killing anybody not killing anybody um
in your heroism can actually go down if
you go the other way if you're you know
getting shot a lot of times raising a
lot of la alarms and that sort of thing
and what it affects is how long the
soldiers that you Fulton back to base
actually take to come over your side
because if you think about it you're
actually kidnapping these guys you know
then I'd join you this is like the
brainwashing meter yeah it's your brain
washing meter cuz you know if if big
boss comes back from every mission and
he is like carved in bullet holes and
blood you kind of be like we want to
follow this guy into battle anymore you
know so they did they explain that in
this video no not at all that we just
suspect that war
exactly the same way as peace walk yes
exactly i think it could also you know
affect certain other things that we
don't know about but you know later down
the line you'll see there are some other
ways to also gain heroism as well okay
so also on this screen we can see a list
of missions in the top left and just to
the right of the mission names is an
icon and if you look at the top right
you can see northern kabul afghanistan
with the same icon that's listed on the
mission list on the left so we kind of
assume that those indicate what map that
mission is going to take place on and
you can also see that you know there are
some other ones that hexagon next to
number two in the ? I'm going to assume
his mother base yeah because mother base
is based on lots of hexes and straps and
northern Kabul Afghanistan as we've seen
is very mountainous exactly yeah yep and
there is another icon later on which is
uh looks a bit like a forest which we
can assume is going to be Africa we
haven't really seen any forest areas yet
know exactly yeah yeah and I have no
idea what that very top icon is it looks
like a kind of Olympic podium with a
plus on it what is that church perhaps
is that like its mission 0 so maybe it's
snake sort of giving his confessional
before he sent there oh you know what
that probably is probably the hospital
where Oh God oh yeah of course yeah yeah
yes or in the initial phantom pain
totally so that would probably count as
like a small self-contained map but
people have been speculating that there
is actually a third map a large map that
has have not been revealed yet okay
alright so the next thing we look at is
some of the weapon customization options
that you're going to have in the phantom
pain and we kind of see here that each
weapon has a number of stats that
weren't present in ground zeroes I think
most of this was kind of under the hood
because you had no chance to customize
those weapons in the first place and
down the bottom in the yellow text we've
also got some attachments that you have
the option of adding to the weapon
itself so you can see we've got a
different kind of scope on the top and
the actual red dot sight as well looks
like it's also customizable and this
this is the first time that weapon
cousin is
has really been in metal gears oh right
yeah from what I understand the research
and peace walker wasn't really that
comprehensive at least down to this kind
of micro level so it's definitely the
kind of thing that plays into the
blueprints that you find out in the map
as well you know you'll get them you'll
send them back to mother base you'll
develop them and then you can kind of
call in a weapon with those
customizations added okay from here we
can see that a snake has sent quiet out
to scout the base and she's actually
that's her marker there she's kind of
running around spotting things and you
can see those hexagon icons on the map
are actually ammo stockpiles and one of
the things she's done is actually
seemingly brought some mo back up to you
and what I don't know is whether she
actually retrieves that and steals it
from the base and brings it out to a
place where you can easily access it or
if she's just seen it and kind of marked
it on the map for you but either way it
looks like sending her in as the scout
beforehand is going to be really really
useful just for not only marking enemies
but finding supplies and all that sort
of thing that's odd though because this
is what you've been doing with your
binoculars in ground zeroes emphatic
yeah so does she / yeah the idea that
she provides assistance in retrieving
things it makes sense because otherwise
could be basically useless well totally
I mean like a lot of the bodies seem to
be replacements for using that kind of
binocular recon functionality right so
d-dog automatically marks people in a
radius quiet can be sent in to scout and
mark people and I think they wanted to
give them unique functions beyond just
that recon ability as well to make them
distinct of bodies yeah it's a wonder
that they don't see like this huge cloud
of smoke yeah yeah it's kind of that
weird so it's like how le in the last of
us was just invisible to enemies as well
yeah they're kind of like okay for
gameplay purposes she practically
invisible okay so we're back to Big Boss
deploying in a mission again in a
different way and you can see when he
chooses his deployment point it actually
marks the alert level of the outpost as
low so what that means is that it seems
like not every mission you want to take
is going to put you in a place where the
enemies don't know you're coming or
they're not already alert to your
presence
and I think that's going to play into
what you do in a free roam mode in the
open world so when you leave a
missionary oh you have the option to
actually go and attack outposts and take
them over but if you fail that I'm
guessing is going to raise their alert
level and kind of keep them you know
suspicious yes I'm messing up an outpost
takeover and them being aware that you
exist we obviously raise their awareness
and might make future missions more
difficult yes it's going to change how
you want to approach that mission
because now you're not going to be able
to get in as close before you reach a
target or that's kind of cut thing so
one of the things that was missing from
Ground zeroes was the camouflage index
which was introduced in Metal Gear Solid
3 Snake Eater and that measured how
hidden you were in the environment based
on the clothes that you were wearing
right in ground zeroes you still could
hide in the environment but you had to
go prone in large at all brass and there
wasn't really any camouflage outside of
that it was more cover and line of sight
base but we can see here in the
deployment screen that snake is wearing
a tiger striped camouflage fatigue and
in the tooltip in the top right it says
that you can wear it on rocky surfaces
to blend in so it sounds like we're
still going to have some kind of a
camouflage functionality back here is
great because that was the best part of
mgs3 totally totally but you remember in
mgs3 you had to keep going into the menu
and changing it like every five minutes
based on moving through the environment
and that sort of thing but it seems like
here you can only set it out in the
loader yeah so that's really interesting
like you deploy with one camouflage
option maybe you could call them in as a
Supply Drop admission which would be
kind of cool yeah but did sea snake get
his stealth suit and one of the early
exactly exactly but it sounds like
you'll then be stuck with that for the
rest of the mission as well so based on
the environment you're deploying in and
how much you know about the map is going
to change what kind of camo you deploy
in the next mission with so the other
thing we can see is that your chopper is
also customizable you can see in the
background on the top right there zebra
stripes zebra stripe skins yeah I'm not
entirely sure if its weapons and flight
capabilities can be customized as well I
mean we see in this mission when you
deploy you have the minigun that comes
around which wasn't present in the
previous deployment video but you
out the chopper itself is kind of a
character in and of itself as well which
is kind of cool just like your horse
yeah i'm remembering ground zeroes you
could actually customize the the music
at played when it totally needs a good
play ride the Valkyries yeah yep and
that's still definitely present in a
phantom pain as well also zebra stripes
help you camouflage yourself against the
Zebras in the sky those flying African
zebras so we can see here a snake is
clearing out an outpost and once he
captures this guy we're going to get a
pop up on the left side of the screen
says outpost cleared outpost captured
sorry and you can see that this is the
point in which you actually gain the
heroism currency uh what it means by
capturing an outpost I'm not entirely
sure it could be kind of like a far cry
3 far cry 4 situation okle move in a
haze that snake go what a cool guy
exactly exactly we know that taking out
anti-air installations around these
outposts allows you to land your chopper
closer to certain locations yeah so
maybe capturing an outpost actually
changes the deployment of the guards on
the open map itself interesting yeah so
one of the coolest new features of this
video is the blast arm and it has a
couple of different functions so one of
them allows you to basically accelerate
your punch with a rocket boost and not
all out directly measure to it here it
is pretty awesome wait wait for it BAM
but the other function has is basically
a replacement for the Nikita missile
from metal gear solid one yeah so it's a
guided rocket-powered projectile yeah
yeah yeah basically ah but what I found
is that it actually runs on fuel rather
than ammunition so you can see here
after he launches it alright I saw the
mall me to go down yes so in the bottom
right there is a meter just under the
blast I'll icon and you can see that is
depleting as he's flying it around and
you'll see after the punch lands that
starts to regenerate as well and I think
just for gameplay purposes you know
after you fire off your arm you're not
going to be running around with one less
arm he still has an arm mechanic it
would be yeah yeah maybe you can't raise
your weapon or whatever if it's um yeah
BAM done
now is that actually killed that man yes
that is a lethal damage which you can
tell from the red icon under the blast
i'll name but you can see that meters
starting to slowly regenerate there as
well so we know that guards will react
to the way that you approach a previous
mission so for example they will equip
helmets to protect their heads against
your bullets but there are some other
interesting icons on the map which i
noticed him in the top right that may
indicate other possible mission
conditions that could come into play so
you can see there's a Fulton balloon
icon there I'm not entirely sure what
that means I think it means they're
going to be aware of your Fulton's with
probably more accuracy maybe shoot them
down with more vigor it looks like
there's a helmet next to that as well
which could be the bulletproof helmets
we talked about before there's what
looks like a video camera maybe security
camera yeah maybe they will install
security cameras in their outposts are
educated cameras back in the 70s well
they were in ground zeroes yeah yeah
sure that's sure yep and then there was
a gun icon next to that I don't know
what that means a they armed they are
going to harm themselves we should make
you bring guns to this time there was a
moon icon so maybe it's a nighttime and
then there was a sniper icon we do know
that there are actually groups of
snipers that sort of Rome the
mountainside in Afghanistan at least so
maybe they come into play by covering
the outpost with you know their sniper
fire maybe that's sort of the outpost
sort of escalation then yes totally yeah
so the Scylla fair amount of stuff that
we don't know about the phantom pain and
specifically how it's going to integrate
with a metal gear online well right
which is a huge component of it yeah and
it's something that we really haven't
seen that much of I'm assuming there are
going to be some kind of interplay
between the research and unlocks you get
in the phantom pain yeah with the kind
of equipment you can choose to customize
your character within metal gear online
as well but aside from that do is there
anything that you still want to know
about is there anything that is still
mysterious to you Dan yeah the fact that
you can deploy as other characters not
just snake
we're in certain missions is really
interesting to me because you could do
that in peace walker as well for side
missions and but they sort of had
different capabilities and I don't know
how that's going to change the way that
you actually play a mission right and I
don't know how it's going to change the
way that you look for certain soldiers
to Fulton and kidnap you know and
obviously there is still a lot more
we're assuming there's a whole lot more
bodies that are yet to be revealed yeah
yeah I mean we've seen quiet d-dog d
walker and d horse but i'm assuming that
can't just be good right yeah absolutely
with a game this crazy yes cope there
must be so much that we still good I
want to see revolver ocelot coming to
battle no well he's going to have some
sweet you know gun spinning skills that
he can deploy really yeah press triangle
spin your girl exactly well we won't
have long to wait to find out all these
things no September first the Tama first
is when we can play this thing so for
more on the phantom pain and middle
goose like five and Kadeem is lost
masterpiece for Konami staging two gates
work
you